[Applaudissements]
et antoine de caunes et avec no mercy
antoine dakhla merci antoine de caunes
la classe merci antoine vraiment à ça
fait très très plaisir qui viennent sur
le plateau de touche pas à mon poste et
tu le sais je suis très émue d'ailleurs
de toi voilà je voulais te le dire j'ai
envie de te faire un bisou allait encore
entend braver le savant et merci merci
vraiment merci merci nous paie voilà ces
voix là j'ai une équipe
l'anniversaire de télé 7 jours on a pris
sa famille parce que toute sa famille
est le symbole de ce que peut être
aujourd'hui la créativité à la
télévision française toi danton
[Applaudissements]
on te voit plus haut soit raymond à mal
non je suis avec cyril hanouna
mais oui mais là on a fait une soirée
chocola et du coup j'ai ton band est
obligé de mordre dans n'importe quoi
c'est ce que je vais maintenant je
raccroche gérald thuru tu peux abcès qui
avait vu le truc avec la femme à barbe
je suis un gentil tout vu la femme à
barbe
j'ai beaucoup saigné nous assurent ils
j'ai vraiment eu la trouille moi vous
avez vous avez entendu des voix vous
avez senti de la roueyre on a fait cet
exercice et puis on avait fait aussi un
jeu de ouija avec donc et les entités de
l'au delà qui viennent se manifester et
répondre à des questions qu'on leur pose
ouais mais moi j'ai eu quand même un
contact assez privilégiés avec une de
ces entités
on lui a demandé si elle avait un
message personnel pour moi on a attendu
et puis finalement ça s'est dessinée
j'ai on a entendu la voix qui m'a dit en
q2
[Applaudissements]